but first
let's take a trip down memory lane back
to 2020 presidential campaign
when then candidate joe biden told us
this
i'll put in place a plan to deal with
this pandemic responsibly i've already
done it i'm not going to shut down the
economy
i'm not going to shut down the country
but i'm going to shut down the virus
but how
what will he use to shut down the virus
his then advisor and current chief of
staff ron klain gave us a bit of a hint
but we have a federal government for a
reason when this kind of nationwide
threat faces ourselves that the
government the federal government
mobilizes
it only took 11 months into biden's
presidency to scrap that genius plan
look there is no
federal solution this gets solved at a
state level
so in other words they're saying this
was actually the right approach all
along
governors will be empowered to tailor an
approach
that meets the diverse circumstances of
their own states
every state is very different
so perhaps biden has always known this
and just spread the convenient lie that
the federal government and trillions of
dollars in wasteful spending is
necessary to extricate us from this
pandemic
of course now that even biden can't
justify a federally led pandemic
response we have to ask
which states are doing the best job
should we follow the lead of
heavy-handed pro-mandate states like new
york
or pro-freedom states like florida
if you look at the data the choice is
crystal clear
new york with its vaccine passports and
crippling restrictions currently has a
hospitalization rate nearly three times
higher than florida's
likewise new york's death rate over the
last 14 days is over four times higher
than florida's and on top of that
florida's unemployment rate is only 4.7
percent new york's 6.6 percent hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else